hallo du dreckige hunden
[Musik]
es gibt zum glück immer in deutschland
einer der fakten einfach mega der lesung
hoch wie keine ahnung man auf jeden fall
scheiße ich rede von niemand geringeren
einnahmen mit zigaretten bekommen wir
heute zu einem nein das ist das fünfte
tagesprogramm ein video hochgeladen wo
ich auf mein händler von mir reagiert
habe und ich bin lukas binder in den
schneide takter alter und seitdem amélie
welcher viele kleinere youtuber anlage
videos gegen mich aufgenommen
deswegen habe ich einfach mal ansage ein
kompakterer youtube eingegeben und diese
ganzen videos hier entdeckt von der bahn
nicht alles alter geht über mehrere
seiten hinweg und hatten über 2000 video
ergebnis deswegen hab ich mir gedacht
ich suche mir meine veranlagen videos
aus und reagierte heute drauf ich habe
nicht verstanden
ich weiß nicht warum das allemal an
werken warum bin ich ein dummkopf ich
schneide
wie kommt man darauf in dem video auf
dass ich hörte man reagiert habe von dem
youtuber rauchverbot hat er auch gesagt
in der schweine character artist video
ich bin nicht der einzige kicker übrigen
bin ich mit den krank und erkältet also
ich glaube aber das hat man schon nach
meiner stimme tut mir leid
er wurde von ihm auf war muss gibt
angeblich geputscht
also konkret aber auch verwundet wurde
von kongresse geprüft warte warte warte
aber diese weise jungen kleines kind ich
weiß nicht wie alt wird dadurch wird man
sagen lieben oder so er sagt
ist durch rauchverbote gepusht wurde
wurde von ihrem raum muss jetzt
angeblich geputzt und dann wird der
darauf verbot durch mich gepusht wurde
offen wurde von konkreter gepusht muss
man das verstehen
ok standart mich ausmacht was da genau
hierauf mit youtube und obligatorisch
auch mit youtube will man nicht sehen
aber eine diesem schon ein traum der
ernsthaft die alle dagegen
warum warum dagegen schneiden geht ins
kino
wahrscheinlich nicht mal angeschnitten
wird oder ich finde das video anlage an
klappt dann genannt wird sofort youtube
[Musik]
youtube ich von ihm
der minecraft videos von ihnen nicht so
gern was laberst du mein kommentare wie
ihn findet
wow wow wow leute wir haben hier
wirklich einen überhaupt talentierten
anlage macher er in ein paar positive
gegenüber mir eingestellt er hat
verstanden hast du dreckige woher aber
wieder da dachte wirklich gerade sagen
hey der da hat ein typ der war positiv
gegenüber mir der hat nicht gelobt
[Musik]
gefeiert und mache weiter in sein vater
war ein kopf schießt mein vater war ein
call auf jeden fall im herzen wer
getroffen worden war
400 woche lotto
ich dachte entkommen wirklich anlage
video von ihnen beiden typen die
demontage muskeln trainieren können so
barbara bach und ihn sofort auf mich
drauf und wollen ein vater war ein kauf
[Applaus]
ich kenne ich bin will ich meine
vorgehen der seien sogar gerade kurz
eine pause macht auch mit während im
einen und mal in folge die leuchte im
dunkeln mit dem wir haben jetzt nicht
ein parcours da könnt ihr euch auch hier
wieder ein video also wirklich einfach
ein video hochgeladen mit dem titel mega
anlageklassen auf youtube
naja also in den ersten zehn sekunden
hat mir jetzt nicht gehört und dann hat
nur ein standbild gesehen von dem
interesse von mir aber wir schauen wir
mal weiter an
wo jetzt noch immer nicht gesagt es
immer noch relativ sturm das video aber
wir geben dem ganzen noch eine chance
also muss man erst mal hinkriegen wenn
wir jetzt in den mega ansager kaum
klappen dann einfach nicht sagen war
keine ansagen sondern eher ein standbild
auf jeden fall mit dem daumen hoch
bewertet und jetzt meine ansage als kaum
kräfte alter was denkst du etwas
putzfrau verboten morgen
wie gehen wir damit in diesem video hier
schon von bei leuten gesagt wurde sich
rausgeputzt hätte er mich auch genau und
ich habe darauf reagiert und hat einfach
darauf geantwortet verstauen alter genau
das meine ich sagte abonnenten auch
lauter kann
aber wenn hier anscheinend nur um die
abonnenten wie wert denn wenn du content
wurde hier der den leuten gefällt häufig
bedeutet dann abonnenten weil irgendwie
bezieht sich nur auf diesen faktor wie
du mich aufrichtig sagen entschuldigung
weil möchte tut mir leid liebe user name
weiß ich nicht aber ich glaube es war
irgendwas mit verbot drin oder so es tut
mir leid dass ich auf ein video reagiert
habe mit dem du gar nichts zu tun hat
ich kann auf jeden fall verschieden dass
dadurch die kredite für die renk fühlt
das gemeint ich dadurch kann schon gar
nicht nur um die abonnenten also leute
ich weiß nicht mehr ganz wichtig auch
mit verboten nachdem anna broda damit
dass zufriedene schönen tag erst einmal
der oder die täter suchen
er meint es gibt ein video habe mir
einfach von kindern vor irgendwann
bitten und ich denke einfach nur wow
kisten oder jetzt werden wir nach den
bällen konnte bin ich ein böser mann tut
mir leid ich entschuldige mich dafür
vielleicht sagt er gleich beruf führt
also wir können auf jeden fall
festhalten ich bin ein böser mann weil
ich bin und außerdem richtig nach
scheiße ich weiß zwar nicht wann das
letzte mal hat mir vorgeworfen ich bin
böse ich bin ein böser mann weil ich
böse bin und ich nicht in der scheiße
und jetzt was sie mir die luo ping kopf
und jetzt regina greife nach seit wochen
[Musik]
am ende wurde spart also diese ansage
von limitierten oder dem blog oder keine
ahnung was hat mich am meisten getroffen
wird er von allen leuten ich weiß ich
hab ich mit diesem ganzen hat noch
weiter umgehen kann
es tut mir leid dass ich euch liebe
leute die in diesem video hier erwähnt
habe in irgendeiner form gekränkt habe
ich entschuldige mich jemand bei eur
zubereitet nicht nach ich denke dass ein
böser mensch bin dass ich den weg bahnen
roppel und mein vater den kopf es wird
nicht wieder vorkommen und er am
werkstor egal
das war dirk wieder meine damen und
herren durchgefeiert hat man leichter
und bei den sound bleiben
mache ich ein anlage video irgendwann
mal gegen mich welt also mache selber so
ein video gegen mich wenn ihr das
wirklich partnerin die eventuell
normalfall sich auch irgendwas reagiere
also ein video die für mich aufgenommen
werden oder irgendwas das schreibt mal
ansage und in die kommentare und dann
soll ich ja wie viele interaktionen da
sind und ob er das wollte das nicht
findet neben zwei die eingeblendeten
darauf wie könnt ihr einen kanal
abonnieren dadurch verpasste keine
videos mehr kostenlos und man
württemberger menschen gegen andere
video könnt ihr euch hier anschauen
einfach draufklicken